Speaker 1: Big news out of the January 6th
committee. The House January 6th committee
investigating the Trump riots will have their
next session after kind of a summer break on
Wednesday. And I will try to cover that live
schedule permitting. The big news and Business
Insider has a good article explaining what's going
on January 6th. Committee members say they believe
Trump was responsible for the riot and the panel
might unanimously refer Trump for prosecution.
This would be a really big deal. It doesn't
mean he would be prosecuted. And if he were,
it doesn't mean he would be convicted. And if he
were, it doesn't mean he would go to prison. But
let's just start where we are. The highlights
from this Business Insider report. January six
committee members Schiff and Cheney spoke about
the Capitol riot investigation on Sunday. They
said they both believe Donald Trump committed
wrongdoing, but they said the panel will give
a unanimous verdict either way when it decides
whether to refer Donald Trump for prosecution. So
at the tail end of this committee and the series
of hearings, the committee members will vote and
they will say, are we referring Trump for criminal
prosecution or not? And what Schiff and Cheney are
saying is it will be a unanimous verdict. We won't
come out with a split verdict. We will all decide,
much like a jury. Schiff said he will make the
decision. His decision align with the rest of the
committee so that they act unanimously. We operate
with a high degree of consensus and unanimity. So
there's a couple interesting things here that I
want to discuss in how much we talk about this
ahead of the actual decision. It's going to be
limited because it's just going to be a matter
of waiting and seeing. This is less about whether
Donald Trump actually ends up in prison again.
I do not believe Trump will end up in prison. I
think even if you go to the end of the rainbow to
speak metaphorically to the conclusion to all of
these criminal investigations, even in the event
of a criminal conviction with a sentence. As a
former president, Trump will serve it out in one
of his resorts. It's just he's not going to end up
in prison. And for me, this is actually less about
whether he even is given any prison time. That's
like ten steps away. This is more about another
criminal problem for Trump as he considers running
for 2024. And will it impede him from carrying out
such a campaign? We already know that Donald Trump
has been sued and criminally referred in New York
by the attorney general, Letitia James. We talked
about that last week. We know that as a result of
the FBI search warrant served at Mar a Lago, that
is likely a criminal investigation that is moving
well ahead and rather quickly. That's another
legal problem we know about what's going on in
Georgia where Donald Trump, remember, he needed
I need 11,000 votes. Give me a break. A probable
wrongdoing there potentially charges. So
the question is now, with the addition
of a potential criminal referral from the
January six committee, is this just going
to mark up his trying to run in 2024? Now I get
it. Many of you are like, oh, David, come on,
six years of this and nothing. It's but bombshell
after bombshell and yet nothing as we continue to
see evidence of Trump's wrongdoing. I'm with you.
I'm with you. And if I had to issue a defense for
why, we should remain cautiously optimistic. And
again, I'm not even sure that we should. But if
I wanted to make that case, the four years Trump
was in office, he was protected to some degree by
his own attorneys general. He had a completely
corrupt in his pocket Republican Party, who,
even if they didn't love Trump, they weren't going
to say much about it publicly, other than the rare
handful of folks like, you know, Mitt Romney
and this ridiculous you know, some of them
call it a rule. It's really sort of like a what, a
tradition. I don't even know where the Department
of Justice doesn't indict sitting presidents.
And some Republicans are giving the Department
of Justice really shouldn't even investigate a
sitting president. So that's all gone now. So
now what Trump is dependent on or reliant upon is
can can corrupt judges save him? And the truth is.
There could have been a federal Trump indictment
any time since January for the Mueller probe if
they wanted to do that. A January of 2021.
But they haven't. He's no longer a sitting
president. The evidence is all still available. So
I share everyone's sort of skepticism, but I try
to maintain some degree of cautious optimism. And
in the next three months, particularly, I mean,
we're only six, five and a half, six weeks
away from the six weeks from the midterms.
There is the belief that after that, there may
be action. But I'm with you guys. You know,
I'm not naively wide eyed and bushy tailed
holding my breath for these indictments.
They clearly should come. But whether they will,
we will find out. Let me know what you expect.
Find me on Twitter at D Pacman after the break.
I'm actually going to have for you some positive
examples of how Democrats need to be talking about
the tomfoolery of the Republican Party. Stay with
us. Folks memberships are available, but they're
running low. Grab yourself a membership at join
pack msn.com. It is the number one way to support
the work we do. Every time a child or an adult
gets a membership. Alex Jones cries a little bit.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want to
make money. Yeah. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Imagine that every single one of these
memberships irritates conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones just a teeny tiny bit. If only he could
monetize with valuable bonus content rather
than the stuff he sells on his store. Okay,
join pack. Mint.com is the place to sign up